one thing that we kind of like glossed
over in terms of japan things that i
want to talk about though
is the music i thought the music was
fantastic i thought it was phenomenal
and i i i think that definitely some of
it it made some it it was what helped
make some of the scenes
that main track i think it played most
of the first episode
when the main character was running back
to a family that kind of slow piano i
think song
i love that track because it's really
positive sounding and
yet putting it next to the absolutely
devastating visuals yeah it's just
becomes
such a creepy song where it's like oh
everything and everyone is dead because
like
i think that well like what sold me on
the first two episodes was just
seeing seeing some of these like
horrific scenes horrific landscapes and
hearing this
beautiful piano track that just gave
this like juxtaposition
that just like it was really unnerving
but beautiful at the same time like i
the way i described it to sydney was it
felt like i was watching some
something that was horrifically
beautiful yeah and i
that that was it was like a beautiful
destruction yeah yeah exactly and i
don't know who the composer was
it sounded very similar to devilman
crybaby's soundtrack in
some scenes as well i don't know if it's
the same composer did i probably should
have done my research before talking
about japan sings on his podcast i mean
i'm sure
it was done by science sarah who did you
know devil may cry baby so i assume it's
the same
guy but i don't know i'm sure someone in
the comments can tell us about that but
yeah i love that piano track because i
don't know it
i'm not gonna lie the first time i heard
it i it kind of reminded me of the
minecraft soundtrack
a little bit i was like if this played
during minecraft
i would not be phased in any way i
thought [ __ ] damn it
can someone in the subreddit take that
piece of music and
put it over minecraft let's play it and
see if you can spot it
it's like god this was such horrific
beauty this the juxtaposition was
amazing
joey minecraft it sounds like my problem
that's what i was like oh minecraft i
don't know if i'm just dumb but i cannot
remember any of the music
you really can't no i can't remember
i watched it all in one sitting though
yeah we all did yeah did you
watch your one sitting yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay i remember we just have a
bigger brain
clearly i think i was preoccupied how do
they get a tank
okay a question to you then what kind of
osts do you remember what sticks out for
you then
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
anything where like the music is like a
huge selling point i guess
you are what what what do you mean ah i
mean i don't want to be that guy but
like the one that sticks out immediately
he's like are you remember cowboy bebop
like this oh
yeah jazzy like but i wouldn't listen to
jazz on its own i'm like so i'm like
this just sounds like a mess
i mean i've come to understand that when
it comes to music you're a little bit
brain dead
yeah because you don't you don't really
listen to because you know god and i can
have a conversation of oh this band is
awesome
and yet i i i remember i asked connor
once i was like who's your favorite band
and he was just like i don't really have
one i'm like
i like no i like daddy punk you know why
because it's just noise most of the time
like i i hate like i never listen to
lyrics like i
i love like listen to like i think i
listened to like popped up kicks
like a thousand times or someone was
like it's about school shooting and i
actually listened to it yeah
like oh yeah i guess it is i don't know
if i'm just like
i don't know what's wrong with me you
want monkey brain
it's that monkey brain coming back man i
have like half a monkey brain half giant
brain depending on like what i can do
you know a single composer
kevin penkid i was like aside from kevin
franken because he's our [ __ ] mate
he's he's
like he said he's not composing our
minds he's just a man
do you know what he composed of the
maiden abyss uh yeah
of god shield hero yeah okay okay
it's pretty the boy's not completely
brained dude that's good i guess because
i focus more on voice acting than
anything and that's like
taking up all the noise input i can take
right like
i don't really give a [ __ ] about the
music to me the music is just
does the music not enhance your viewing
experience the music to me is so [ __ ]
important no no not really like like if
if if uh if there's a shitty series with
a good soundtrack i'm still going to
remember that
i absolutely agree to this day like i
will never forget guilty crown
despite how a [ __ ] guilty crown turns
into
sour no [ __ ] killed it with that
sound that openings are [ __ ] this
yeah
songs that like will invoke an emotion
in me from like if they've been a
soundtrack
but as far as it goes it's like but have
you never listened to a song on a
soundtrack and just gotten pumped up no
not at all like uh maybe at the gym like
i'll put anime soundtrack to get hyped
too and maybe a you know
okay but but say for example premiere
yeah you [ __ ] love that music right
it was a great movie do you remember the
soundtrack no
how how is it that the most
in your face composer that has ever
existed in anime
connor's like if you were like if you
were like no impression if you like like
describe a song to me from from i'd be
like i have no [ __ ] idea
no
yeah i remember like individual songs
but if you ask me like describe them or
what i like about them i'd be like
they're all like crayon colors too i
don't know like for all i care you could
put like [ __ ] kevin macleod music
whatever
kevin mccloud mcleod that he's called
how you put kevin mcleod background
creative commons composers
you know you can put those [ __ ] songs
to be fair some
of the best shows i've listened to have
made like some kevin mccloud music
there's like there's definitely been
some generic sounding soundtracks that
but they're normally like for generic
shows right but yeah i don't know a
soundtrack can
easily sell me a series i wish i could
give a [ __ ] i don't know
[Music]
i it's with music as well i love daft
punk i i just like wow the scent the
noise sounds nice
like i like the noise you know what i
mean is that weird is that weird
yes it is it is very weird yeah i know i
think you just
basically described music in in the most
like
i think
i think i actually am like a caveman
when it comes to music i'm like oh
the beeps in the boobs are very pleasing
music goes
yeah yeah music goes i mean that's a
huge reason
when it comes to soundtracks that's a
huge reason why i love
anything made by uh key studios right
because yeah jun
is a [ __ ] amazing composer and he's
like just subtle piano
tracks or any of the openings and
endings just it builds
on the scene so [ __ ] nicely and it
adds like a whole like
totally like at least to me i don't know
maybe i'm the only one but i could
just listen to say any track from
clannad or air
or little busters yeah and it could be a
specific song that can evoke a specific
scene and i could easily shut
it just from listening to it like his
work is basically if you want to hit
the emotional g-spot yeah you know what
i mean like you hear it and you're like
oh oh [ __ ] no it feels like how does a
single piano put this much emotion
behind it
i have no [ __ ] idea you're like the
mike was asking me more he's just
standing there right now
this conversation because you guys died
i don't know you are the first person to
ever describe darf punk is noise
it's like i'm just saying present noise
is the way i like it
you mean music interstellar three
whatever it's called what is it
interstellar
five five
has the track never evoked emotions from
you though
like have you ever listened to actual
evil emotions okay what's your favorite
punk track well that's hard i really
like face to face okay why is it your
favorite track
oh my god is it because it invokes an
emotion you've seen his face he's never
thought about this
before i don't know why is this my
favorite song no i i like all the
sampling in it i think it's like crazy
how creative they are with sampling
right so you're looking at them so is
there okay think about the one
daft punk song it doesn't have to be
dark just think about the one song that
has evoked like
any kind of emotion in you what song
would that be and what emotion would
that be
yeah i i don't think there is i don't
think there is a song that evokes
emotions in me
is that mad is that what does it mean
what does that mean about me as a person
i'm talking to a [ __ ] brick wall here
i'm like
oh